HOST: So welcome.
Welcome Athenistas to Google--
for today's talks at Google.
It's interesting that
both of our companies,
which are technology
companies in the 21st century,
actually have names for
our employees-- Athenistas
and Googlers.
And hopefully some
of the Athenistas
and some of the Googlers
will mix it up here today.
We're here today for talks
at Google with Jonathan Bush.
That's all right-- if we can
have that-- the ratio doesn't
have to be perfect.
JONATHAN BUSH: School
here or abroad.
Just think of it as
an exchange program.
HOST: So we're here to talk with
Jonathan Bush, whose book just
came out, Where Does It Hurt?
An Entrepreneur's Guide
to Fixing Health Care.
I was just speaking with
one of Jonathan's associates
who asked me if I was
familiar with the book.
And I've actually read the book.
And in fact, you can actually
see some notes in the margins.
JONATHAN BUSH: Did you
read it on paper too?
HOST: I read it on paper, yes.
I actually read
this on a plane--
JONATHAN BUSH: There's
still some left, people.
This is what they look like.
HOST: So Jonathan
is, in addition
to the author of this book,
which I recommend highly--
it really does make a very, very
complicated topic much easier
to understand.
It also makes a very complicated
topic possibly very scary
for some of us who haven't
seen all our way through it.
But in addition to being a
soon to be best selling author,
Jonathan, also the president CEO
and chairman of Athena Health
which he co-founded in 1997.
He took public in 2007 when
it was the most successful IPO
of the year, and continues to
thrive and grow today in 2014.
HOST: Yes?
Were you going to say--
JONATHAN BUSH:
That's what I do when
I'm feeling full of myself.
I just do that.
HOST: OK.
But we're not going
to necessarily talk
deeply about the business today,
although we'll get to that.
We'd like to talk about
the book, which is just as
much the Jonathan story
and the health care story
as it is the Athena
Health story.
So Jonathan-- I'll
start you off with kind
of a life of Jonathan question.
You graduated from Wesleyan,
the College of Social Studies.
Is that correct?
JONATHAN BUSH: Yes.
HOST: How does a graduate
of Wesleyan College--
or what does a person do when
they graduate from Wesleyan
in the College of Social Studies
to work their way to this?
What was the path?
What were some of
the motivations?
What were some of the
inspirational epiphany moments
that happened then,
right after then,
right before then that
eventually got you to 1997?
JONATHAN BUSH: Well, I think
I'll go a little bit earlier.
And I was actually-- I
was one of the few people
to receive early
rejection from a college.
So that's where you apply
early and they don't refer you
to the general admission pool.
They say wow, you are so far
off in terms of your goals
that we're going to
help you by saying
that you'll never come here.
HOST: OK.
JONATHAN BUSH: And--
HOST: Was that Wesleyan?
Was that Wesleyan?
JONATHAN BUSH:
That was Wesleyan.
Which, of course, was
immediately to me was like,
I'm coming there.
And so I took a year
off and I went to BU
and I got good
grades-- which was
exhausting-- the good grades.
But I did it.
And then I came
back and I got in.
And I really wasn't-- after
all that effort getting good
grades, I realized I wasn't
really good at anything.
At anything.
I wasn't good at sports,
and I wasn't good at math,
and I wasn't good
at science, and I
wasn't good at literature.
But I liked all of it.
And I liked the idea of being
a little better at all of it.
And the College
of Social Studies
was an interdisciplinary
program--
that was history, government,
economics, and philosophy--
in little colloquia that
you go through intensively.
And I-- it would
intensively do it.
Did a bad job at all of them.
But there were only
a few of us who
would dare try to
take all of those on.
And it worked wonders
for my dyslexia,
and it gave me an
incredible confidence
at seeing the broad
stroke of things.
And that's why--
Wesleyan's president just
wrote a book on why
liberal education is
useful in an era of
comp-sci and [INAUDIBLE]
it's about seeing the
broad stroke of things.
In health care that's,
particularly hard to do.
In fact, there are
years and years
of well intentioned law
making it almost illegal
to see the broad
stroke of what's
happening in health care.
So that's how it got started.
And it was in fact, the idea of
looking for places where there
was no broad stroke
that made sense,
that got me to health care.
And so Wesleyan was
perfect training.
Who knew?
Also, I was the absolute
best Wesleyan graduate
in health care
management, because there
were no other Wesleyan
graduate anywhere interested
in the management of health
HOST: Great.
So you finished up
at Wesleyan and you
had a couple of
adventures, right?
That actually started to
get you closer to this.
JONATHAN BUSH: Right.
It was-- I graduated
with Wesleyan still
clinging to the idea that
maybe there was something
that I could be good at.
And since the idea of making
a lot of money saving people's
lives appealed and no
one else in my family
had been a doctor except for my
uncle Johnny, who was then 80
and had polio-- and so he
couldn't compete with me.
I thought maybe I'd
be a doctor and I'd
be like-- this was before ER,
but it would be like ER, knight
and I'd save people's
lives and [? work ?].
[INAUDIBLE]
And then I learned about this
whole organic chemistry thing,
and there went that.
But before I discovered
organic chemistry,
I-- a doctor friend-- I said,
like I want to do this doctor
thing and he's a trauma surgeon
who's worked on the President's
rescue squad that flew
around the world case
the President got shot.
And he said, look.
Try before you buy.
I have a friend who's the
police surgeon in New Orleans.
Get a job, get your
EMT certification,
and get a job treating patients.
And then decide if you want to
put seven years of your life
into being bad at school again.
And and I did, and I didn't.
And I'm really glad I
didn't go all the way
through medical school
and have this experience.
But I absolutely loved
driving an ambulance at six
at night to 6:00 in the
morning in New Orleans.
It was the greatest
experience-- I think, probably
in my career to date--
including everything
that's happened now to date.
Partly because of the romance
of being honored with the one
thing that is going
truly horribly
wrong amongst a million people.
Right now amongst the 5 million
people in Massachusetts,
there's some horrible
thing happening.
And to be the one entrusted
to help in that moment
and be allowed to
race to that place
is romantic and
important and beautiful.
But also, the whole system.
You get to travel
through the whole food
chain from the back
room of the house
all the way through
the emergency room
and into the operating room
and see all the hand offs.
Which, if you like the
broad stroke of things,
provides an extraordinary
front row seat.
And really inspiring business
ideas come out of that.
One business idea was,
wow, EMT's go things better
than doctors.
Paramedics can put in lines
and tubes better than doctors
because we do them all
the time in a moving
ambulance with someone
who's trying to kick us.
And that's really good practice
for being able to get it right.
Another idea -- so
can't we downscale?
Can we create different
specializations below doctor
and make care cheaper?
That was an idea
that came out of it,
went into Athena women's health.
Another one was
most of the people
we treated in an ambulance
didn't need to be transported.
They needed a little
bit of stabilization,
a little bit of help, a little
bit of emotional support.
And we weren't
allowed to do that.
If we didn't transport
them, we'd get no money.
If we did transport
them, we'd get $495.
So treating in place remains an
enormous business opportunity
for somebody who
likes that stuff.
And that's what got me
going on this whole,
how does the whole
thing fit together?
How could it fit together
differently idea.
HOST: Great.
That was followed by, as we
refer to it here in Cambridge,
the B school.
And--
JONATHAN BUSH:
--Temple of capitalism.
HOST: Yeah, OK.
The temple of capitalism if we
didn't catch that on the mic.
And consulting.
Right?
JONATHAN BUSH: Booz-Allen.
Yeah, there another to
fail again at something.
So I was able to get
into the business school
about seven minutes before the
meeting where they were going
to sit me down and talk
about how it's not working.
I just was with spreadsheets
and the footnotes
and getting it all right.
I was terrible.
HOST: OK.
JONATHAN BUSH: I loved the
problems we were solving,
but once I saw what the
answer was, the seven
months of billing for
PowerPoint analysis of it
all just was torture.
I think probably a lot
of people come to Google
for that reason instead
of going to [? DC. ?]
HOST: Or they've perhaps made
a stop there and end up here.
JONATHAN BUSH: That's right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
HOST: They've made the stop
there and they end up here.
We definitely have
a lot of those folks
here, as you imagine.
So then the time comes
to start a business.
Inspiration, market--
identifying a market
opportunity, inspiration.
Athena Health starts as--
JONATHAN BUSH: Yeah,
well it started
as a series of women's health.
And alternative
to maternity care.
A holistic approach
And it took all the things I
learned as an ambulance driver,
as an army medic was even more
extreme examples of delegation
down below the M.D. level.
And became very clear.
I did the work at business
school-- Harvard Business
School is great because
people call you back.
Say I'm doing research at
Harvard Business School.
Oh, maybe I'll call
them back, sort
of like I'm calling from Google.
I'll call back on that.
And built a model that showed
that-- some breakthrough
insights like, not everybody
who's pregnant is also sick.
But in the United States,
everybody who's pregnant
gets treated like they're
sick, like they're just
about to blow any moment.
When, in fact, it's a thing.
In fact, the first
doctor turns out
to have been the subject of a
perfectly healthy pregnancy.
That's a joke, because
the doctor was--
HOST: Yes.
JONATHAN BUSH: And so the
idea of matching health
advocates to healthy women
and to help fewer of them
actually end up in
need of a doctor,
and then matching doctors
to unhealthy women,
and therefore those women
got the benefit of a better
doctor who's actually
spending all of their time
with sick moms.
Created better doctors,
much lower cost of care.
And it was great, except
we ran it into the ground
because we couldn't get paid.
We couldn't figure out all
of the various accounting.
Get the hospital
information, and the lab,
and the pharmacy, and
the anesthesiologists,
and the neonatologists
all in one picture.
We couldn't even
get our own claims
paid because there was no
code for a nutritionist doing
a visit instead of a midwife,
even though the exact right
person to do it was a midwife.
Or nutritionist, et cetera.
HOST: So can you just slow
down on that point for just
a second.
The year is what when
this is happening?
JONATHAN BUSH: This
was '97 through '99.
HOST: '97 through '99.
Explain again how you
had trouble getting paid.
Again, a lot of folks in this
audience will understand that.
But this video will be posted on
YouTube if 280,000 subscribers
to that YouTube channel.
And so while they'll be
very thoughtful people,
they may need a
little bit more--
JONATHAN BUSH: So you
guys on the street.
You ever get a bill in
the mail from a visit
and it's got the thing you
tear off in the envelope,
and then it says
this is not a bill?
You ever get one of those,
like from a lab like LabCorp
or whatever, and
you're like-- it
says amount due and everything,
but it says this is not a bill,
and you're like,
well what do I do?
Or an EOB for your kids it's got
lots of little rows and columns
and codes, and you're
like so what do I do?
Doctors, they do
that-- that's all--
it's like filing
your taxes every day.
That's what it's
like being a doctor.
Everybody you see, everything
you do has to be defended.
It has to be charged for
in one of 7,000 different--
what's called CPT.
Procedure codes.
And then the
procedure codes need
to be defended by
one of 10,000--
soon going to 140,000
different ICD diagnostic codes.
And then you have to
write little bits that
explaine why those were
the right diagnostic codes.
And then you file your
taxes-- file your claim,
and you get this paid.
Well that is
exhausting if you do
it exactly the way
everyone else does it.
But if you try to mix it up
and do a bundle of things that
aren't normally bundled
together or use somebody that
isn't the doctor
that usually does it,
the coding and defending
and documenting
and tax filing energy
goes right up to 11.
And that's what Athena ran into.
And that's what everybody
in health care runs into.
I want to do it better, I
want to do it different.
And then they find out what
it takes to just do it at all
and they get bogged down.
The notion of a
health care cloud.
Just like Google with-- I
mean, I don't know the age.
But the amazingness of Google
is hard to put into words.
You just put the
words in the box,
and it pretty much gives you
the thing you're looking for.
That's ridonculous.
I mean, that's amazing.
Right?
I don't get it,
but it's awesome.
And what health care
doesn't have-- now
health care is more difficult.
There's security issues
and there's privacy issues
and there's
complexity issues that
make that just calling what's
out there not sufficient.
But it seems like
we were thinking
at the time, God it would be
great if some of this muck
could just be called and handled
and linked in the background.
And I could say in English what
I did, or what I want to do,
and why.
And then whoever needs to
speak claims-ish or filing-ish
can translate it through
Google translator
and tell whichever claims
system that needs to know.
And that was where Athena-- it
was the idea of not being able
to sufficiently code
for, get paid for,
exchange information
around what we were doing
that caused us to start
to build our own cloud.
They couldn't afford
the enterprise
software was available.
We had a-- my co-founder's
younger brother
was president of the
Harvard computer club.
They were like the
technical support people
that volun-- that you could
pay to join at Harvard.
And he got two of his
friends and they came out
for the summer.
HOST: And this was in San Diego?
JONATHAN BUSH: Yeah.
And they-- we were all living
in these two flop houses
where we all took
little spaces of carpet.
Really good
wall-to-wall carpeting.
So we just thought
it's so clean.
HOST: That's a '90s thing too.
JONATHAN BUSH: Yeah.
Use it.
And it was great.
And it was amazing tacorias, so
we didn't-- the food was fine.
And--
HOST: We'll get to why
you ever left in a--
JONATHAN BUSH: It was tough.
It was tough.
If it wasn't for
my then wife saying
she'd leave me-- which she
did anyway 10 years later,
I'd still be there.
For good reason,
I'm a workaholic.
But wow.
Amazing experience.
And what he started
to say-- what our CTO
and what other guys started
to say is, look-- you,
we should just write this.
We should just write
this ourselves.
We were downloading stuff
into Microsoft Access tables
and pivoting and
figuring out what
we needed to report
to whom that way.
But after a while, it-- why
can't we just write this.
And so we started writing
a little applet that
crawled the state
Medicaid website.
In California, it's
called Metacal,
to see if people-- they put
in different-- screen scrape
different names or numbers
that we had from our front desk
and see if we could
figure out they
were covered that month
for state assistance.
And then we started figuring
out how to automatically add
the modifiers that you have to
use to do the same coding when
it's a midwife seeing the
patient instead of a doctor.
And little by little
by little-- what we now
call lean development,
but at the time,
we called just fix one
more thing development.
It started to grow
like wall mold
through different
parts of the practice.
And pretty soon,
even though I'd said
I went to the temple
of capitalism,
I know the theory of
comparative advantage.
We're a health care company,
not a technology company.
Therefore we will
buy our technology
and and trade and build our
health care service experience.
It just happened.
The wonderful thing about
Perl and internet coding
and the lean
development process that
is allowed in that we can
talk about the software
enabled service business model.
It almost takes on
a life of its own.
It almost starts to-- It's
so easy for so many people
to see the problem.
And it's so easy to solve
it, and it's so hard
to stop them from solving the
problem that it sort of just
goes at the pace
of the imagination.
As opposed to, we're
going to have a plan,
we're going to march out,
we're going to set up,
we're going to climb
the hill, and then we're
all going to do it.
And at the end of the
year, have another plan.
It's more of a jazz
band than an orchestra.
HOST: So the business
model essentially changes
from a service--
JONATHAN BUSH: That's right.
We decided that we
were too far ahead.
That we were a business
that needed a health care
cloud to exist.
And so what we were going to do
is build the health care cloud.
We were going to build-- So we
changed the vision statement
of the company.
It was Athena Women's
Health is going
to be a management
infrastructure that
helps make women's
health work as it should.
And we switched it
to Athena Health--
not Athena Women's Health--
will be an information
infrastructure that helps make
health care work as it should.
And once we did that,
we were opened up
to selling to anybody.
And they didn't have to
use our unique model.
They could be any
way they wanted
as long as they
wanted to connect.
And that that connection
fabric would somehow, someday
be the sub strata that people
could then build businesses
on top of.
And sure enough,
the book is exciting
because that was this
ridiculous idea 16, 15 years ago
to try to keep
people from quitting.
I'm like, wait.
No, no!
You don't understand.
Because then it's going to
be like this sub strata,
and then there's going to
be all these Athena Women's
Health that are built on
top, and you're like, OK,
I won't quit for another month.
But stop with the
talk about the stuff.
And here's whatever
there are in the book.
I mean, there's tons of them.
But there's like five
or six in the book
that have-- folks that
have actually done that.
So it's actually happening.
HOST: Right.
So talk a little bit about
actually now building
a new technology company.
Maybe a little bit.
Because in the crowd
here, we probably
have-- even though
you'd like all of them
to work for Athena
forever and we'd
like all the Googlers to
work at Google forever.
They won't, because they're
smart, they're young,
they're ambitious, they'll
have their own ideas.
JONATHAN BUSH: They're
getting very big.
It's scary.
HOST: Talk a little
bit about what
it was like to actually
build this new company.
JONATHAN BUSH: Maybe
we should throw
in your question about
the software and--
HOST: --and still
I'll make it a two
parter about software
enabled services.
And so, essentially, the concept
of building this new company
in what is a new
category, not SAS,
but software enabled services.
What do you mean by that,
and how did you build that?
JONATHAN BUSH: So we didn't--
we named it in retrospect,
because what we wanted to point
out to people was that we were
not SAS.
So you have the--
if you think about,
if you go to science museum
to the Paleolithic exhibit
way back in the cro magnon, here
are there enterprise software.
And you pay millions
of dollars, and you
receive what amounts to a disk.
And then you buy
machines, and you
have consultants which are
these three legged punched that
come and burn in stuff and load
up stuff, and download stuff.
And then they have
classes where people
come to learn how
to follow the ritual
of that particular
enterprise software.
Then there are ASPs
that come after that,
and these are where they have
professional consultants where
you don't have to buy them.
They just are always there
backing it up and hosting it
and doing the
downloads, and you just
pay a little more every month.
And then suddenly, in
comes in a chariot Mark
Benioff and you guys.
And you guys-- although you
guys have a way cooler business
model.
But companies that say, listen.
I'm going to just have
one copy of this thing
up in the world native
on the internet.
And if you like it the way it
is, you can come and use it.
And you're not going to
have to get trained on it,
it's not going to be
installed or downloaded.
And if you've been
using it for a while,
I'm going to start
to charge you.
Or I'm going to
start to sell-- I'm
going to start to show you
stuff that you didn't ask
for so that I can charge
someone else, either way.
And so it's a tool that is used
by people to either service
themselves or service others
native on the internet.
And then the break from
there-- which the muse for me
is [? BASOS-- ?] but
we view ourselves
as an industrial strength,
narrower, deeper Amazon--
is that the software, the
tool is no longer the product.
It's not the monetizable thing.
It's just the store into which
you go to get the service.
So Amazon sells the arrival
of stuff in your life.
Either shipped to you,
hover crafted to you,
or squirted to your Kindle.
And when you get that
stuff, a little piece of it
goes to Jeffrey.
Right?
And he's a peaceful man.
He just wants a little piece
of everything in the world.
And God bless him.
But what it does is, it
changes his business model.
Because now he's
not only in charge
of making a software work.
He's making sure
that people actually
use the software in
a way that he desires
and get outcomes that they
desire in order to monetize.
So Athena-- now,
anybody can use Athena.
And we don't charge
you until you
get a claim paid,
or a chart filed,
or a patient in your office.
It is the event.
It is the work being done
that generates the revenue.
And so if we use the
internet, or carrier pigeons,
or 2000 people in India
data entering paper forms
that the insurance
company just can't
seem to give us electronically,
that's all good.
It can be knowledge,
it can be software,
and it can be bone
crushing work.
Forklifts included.
As long as the result gets
got, the revenue is driven.
That idea opens up so much
of the pre-internet world
to new businesses.
And we found one, but
there are countless others.
And that idea of
a software enabled
service was-- the way it
started for us was we started
as a service that didn't
even want software.
We said, look.
We want a piece of your profits
as a women's health practice.
And they said sure,
and then we said, OK.
How about a piece of your
revenues as any practice?
And little by little, we
keep designing our products
around a piece of the success.
Whatever success is defined
as, a little piece of it.
Which liberates us to do
the kind of lean developing
that a SAS company
can do, but add
non-software, non-technology
arms and legs around it to make
it go faster.
HOST: Right.
So you speak glowingly
of enterprise software.
Earl on, when you're
describing this course.
You're--
JONATHAN BUSH:
--Well in it's time--
[SCREECHING NOISE]
back in the day--
HOST: --Glowingly.
You-- would you--
JONATHAN BUSH: --Rule,
move the jungle.
HOST: But you're-- do you--
are you competing with--
that could be.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
HOST: How do you view
Epic and Cerna today
as a competitor,
as an opportunity--
JONATHAN BUSH: --Look, I think
those are really well run
fabulous companies
of another era.
And that era, I see as over.
But I get to sit at
the theoretical helm
of this incredibly ambitious
visionary group of people that
are constantly pushing,
and pushing, and pushing.
Not every hospital is sitting
at the helm of such a ship.
And so something safe that's
of an era that they understand,
where parking places are
part of your comp packet
with the little name on it.
And think about
hospitals, right?
So a safe thing that's
been going on for years
that uses the same ecosystem of
consultants, and specialists,
and vendors, and
allows the same career
paths that have
always been there.
Going to be the
CIO of a hospital
and there's a special
trade association for them
and-- it's hard to imagine
letting all of that
go until it's very,
very, very safe.
There's that wonderful
book Crossing
the Chasm of-- invention
is amazing and it works,
and the early adaptors
who would happily
deal with all the works
of a new invention,
make you feel like you
finally cracked the code.
And then you get to your
mainstream customers,
and they're like,
Jesus this is a mess.
I hate this.
And you have to go through
this horrible chasm of making
your new age thing work as
reliably as the old age did.
And health care is that way.
So we're having to
get though to a place
where the safety
that people associate
with Cerner and Epic,
which are not safe.
They're systems are down 10,
20, 30 times more than ours are.
And none of the systems
correlate the performance.
Epic doesn't lose money
if they lose your claims
or if you lose your
claims on Epic.
They don't lose
money if your doctors
don't document their charts.
There's no correlation
between your performance
and their performance
like there is with Athena.
But still, that's a scary step.
So was electricity,
and we seem to all
be OK with that at this point.
So was the internet, we seem to
be banging away on that, so--
HOST: --Do you find that
you're getting traction
with the concept of software
enabled as opposed to SAS?
JONATHAN BUSH: For those
who-- for the elites
that are listening to this
YouTube, I think they get it.
So when one of our salespeople
gets in front of somebody
and actually explains the
difference, it's easy.
The word cloud helps people.
So thank God Microsoft spent
all that money for everybody
on the cloud apps.
Let's go to the cloud, kids.
Remember that?
The idea of somebody
who's actually
going to look out for
your particular stuff
in a space, the
iCloud-- that helped.
Because people--
now those things
don't work at the level
of security and fidelity
that Athena net does.
Shouldn't have to for your
photos or your whatever.
But the fact that
at least it's a term
that people can grock and
can start to get ahold of.
And that's helping us.
And Epocrates, which
every doctor understands
and half of doctors
use every day, helps.
HOST: Talk more about that,
because some of the audience
may not be aware that you
guys acquired Epocrates.
JONATHAN BUSH: We did.
HOST: What do they do,
why did you acquire them,
how's it playing out?
JONATHAN BUSH: Epocrates is
the best known and loved--
in terms of Net
Promoter Score brand
in the world of
practicing physicians.
So that's what we love
the most about it.
We also love all the things that
they have done over the last 15
years to earn that love.
I like the way they
think and operate.
It is a decision support tool.
It's a read-only app
that a doctor whips out
in the moment of
care it says I'm
going to raise your dose
because this one's not working.
But I just want to
check to make sure
that this works on men
the way I think it does,
or at your weight.
Or whether the on brand,
whether the off brand generic
is just as effective.
Little questions
that they're not
familiar with
because they're not
doing that prescription
enough that they know it cold,
they'll check it.
There was a thing called the
physician's desk reference back
in the day which was this
book, and they'd say, just
one minute, and
they'd go out and make
sure they weren't killing
you with the wrong dose.
Epocrates is sort of a living,
breathing, interactive version
of that.
And it gives us half
the doctors eyeballs
in the country on a
very regular basis.
And it gives us the
opportunity to use the plumbing
that we've been building.
There are now
100,000 connections
between Athena net and Legacy
Systems labs, pharmacies,
hospitals, and more
being built every day.
And now Epocrates can
start to be wired up
like your Xfinity remote.
Back in that day,
remember the first time
you sent an email
off your BlackBerry
and there was in your Outlook
account, and you're like,
that was awesome!
I didn't even do a
cable, and it's there.
That opportunity to just
stop going into these bowel
based enterprise
software products
but but still have
them if the hospital is
going to be stuck on them.
To be able to drive them
like your Xfinity remote
can change your channel
if you work at Google
and you actually can
figure out how to do it.
That idea is the potentiality
for us of Epocrates.
HOST: So working to
expectations to date?
JONATHAN BUSH: Half and half.
So what they've done
to earn the trust
and loyalty of physicians,
they continue to do.
If bombs were going
off, if the Syrians
were taking over
San Francisco, they
would still be doing it
with barrel bombs going off.
They have not made money.
And so we have to help them
with that is a good thing.
That's the one thing.
And we will.
We will, because
otherwise, we'll die
and we'll all be out of a job.
But I think we can do it.
It's not going to be hard.
HOST: What's the--
JONATHAN BUSH: --sort of like
saying gravity is a thing.
You need the revenue, and--
HOST: Right.
Is there a next big
hurdle for Athena Health?
Or is it--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
HOST: What's the next biggest--
JONATHAN BUSH: I mean this
is a $2 trillion mess.
Just a-- nobody understands it,
doctors don't understand it,
everybody feels-- and
I want to say this.
The thing about
health care that gets
me is not how expensive it is.
That gets me a little.
But really kind
of just cuts at me
is that for all that money,
now taken by force of law--
you can't opt out.
It really isn't an
expression of our humanity.
Think about everything on what
we're wearing, where we work,
where we travel,
whether we travel,
who we date-- everything we
do with our personal power
is a way of tricking ourselves
out and being a person.
And we can change it
if we don't like it,
and we do many
times before we die.
Somehow, health care--
you just take it.
You just pay for it.
It gets taken out
your check like taxes,
and then you just get this
experience that you don't like.
Or that you do, but it's
a pleasant surprise.
It's not like you're
in charge and they're
jumping to get to you.
They're not doing
product management
to be more appealing.
When you see research-- 85%
of Medicare beneficiaries
don't receive their
Medicare wellness visit.
All the research talks
about these idiot Medicare
beneficiaries.
I'm like, you mean my parents?
Well maybe your
wellness visit sucks.
How about that?
Why don't you do it more
interesting than you do it?
If you explain what happened
in a way that's fun,
why don't you do product
management the way
other businesses do?
And I totally forgot how
I got on this tangent.
So everything in health care,
if connected and analyzed,
could start to have
a demand curve it.
Could start to be something
that could do better
with product management
and good pricing,
and do worse without it.
And that would be amazing.
So insurance companies need to
be threatened with extinction.
All the cost management,
and the accounting firms,
and all these guys who are
doing these one offs little
spreadsheets and mailing them
to the doctors about their taxes
need to be threatened
with extinction.
All of these manual, isolated,
guild like-- well only I
understand all the rules.
Only I can speak to Oz.
All of those guys need to be
threatened with extinction
with some kind of product.
Even if it's a piece of crap,
low end disruptive product,
at least it wakes
people up to the idea
that maybe-- like you guys are
doing with travel and movies,
and you're sort of nipping.
It's not quite-- I don't
use you for the movies,
but maybe I do a little
sometimes just to piss
off Fandango.
I just want to-- I love
that everywhere there's
somebody nipping at the
heels of these guilds.
Making sure they're earning
the right for these I'm unique,
only I understand,
only I can speak
to Oz pricing and performance.
And so that-- health insurance,
laboratories, pharmacies,
in-patient care,
home nursing care.
Self care.
We got nothing
going on self care.
Why aren't our Fitbits
connected to our charts?
Why don't our doctor wake
up when we're behind?
Or why don't we get a
really serious discount when
we do actually run
every day for six months
instead of a stupid exploding
thing on the Nike app?
Like, yay.
Nike likes me.
HOST: And you've paid
them a lot to like you.
JONATHAN BUSH: Yeah, right.
For $150 I'd like you too.
So I mean, I'd like
some real money.
I'm spending real money.
Look at our employees-- I
don't know, $20 million?
That's I know for
you guys, that's
valet tips at the Google garage.
But for us, $20 million
is a ton of money
to spend on something
that we make people--
you have to pay it.
And no matter whether
you like it, like ah.
Yeah.
Doesn't feel good.
It's expensive and amazing.
OK.
We're rich.
Rich country, rich company,
let's-- but if it's rich
and lame--
HOST: I'm going to come back to
the industry in just a second.
And I want to get back to the
journey for just a moment.
You had beautiful soft
shag carpets, tacquerias.
But you're in Watertown now.
JONATHAN BUSH: Yeah.
HOST: Why move the company here?
JONATHAN BUSH: Well we founded
the company at 94 Codman Road.
There's a temple
built there now.
A beautiful-- OK, so there's
an apple tree which I planted.
And they haven't cut down.
But it's a ranch house by
the Codman farm in Lincoln.
And it was a split level.
So down the split
was the world HQ
of Athena Health and
the washer and dryer.
And up the split was the
home of the Bush family.
And then in the yard was
the conference center,
which was a Jeep Wagoneer
where we kept flip charts.
The big paper with the markers,
and we'd have meetings.
We dropped the gate down.
And then when we got--
we're like, well let's
just get a local
medical group that we
can work on as our alpha site.
And none of them listened.
None of them--
absolutely not, we're not
going to let you
touch anything it.
Go away.
And then we found
a bunch of kooks.
I had to actually miss
my accounting exam
at Harvard Business school.
I went to the guy and said, I
don't want to fail your course,
but I will if I
have to because I
have to be out of
town for your final.
He said, what on earth would
make you want to do that?
Said well it's the only
time of the American College
of Obstetricians
and Gynecologists
convention in Vegas.
I said, you know I've
been teaching for 30 years
and I had thought
up until this moment
that I had heard
everything but that.
And he let me-- it was
before cellphones--
he let me take the exam
at his house in Belmont.
Put me in a taxi and said,
OK, go to the airport,
don't talk to anyone.
And I went and I found basically
the only obstetricians that
were in the right combination
of brilliant visionary status
and about to go out of business.
Where they would let a bunch
of guys who shared laptops
for savings to save money.
Like, hey, can I use a
laptop? -- to take them over.
And we raised the
amount of money
that we would need to basically
populate their accounts
receivable from angel investors.
So we did that all.
Our world headquarters
was 94 Codman,
but the group happened
to be in San Diego.
So it was like, San
Diego or nobody.
And since we fancied ourselves
a global national chain
of women's health centers, who
cares what your first one is?
Because we were going
to migrate pods.
They were going to be pods.
We'd buy six doctors
in every market
and then hire hundreds of
midwives and nutritionists
around them-- a dual license.
And so it was like,
what's the difference?
So we went for six months,
and it was really in bad shape
after six months.
But we said, we have to declare
victory because if we don't get
another pod soon, we won't--
we're going to run out
of the money.
And and no one will give
us more money when there's
flames in the waiting room
and everybody's unhappy.
HOST: We found--
just want to talk
for a minute about
the local market
again for people who
might be pursuing
their own dreams at some point.
We've had Bill [? Helman ?]
from Greylock in here to talk--
JONATHAN BUSH: --Great guy.
HOST: --to talk about
the local market.
JONATHAN BUSH:
--Greylock dumped me.
Would not put the money.
I send him my quarterly.
I send him my quarterly every
quarter, thinking of you.
HOST: I did not know that.
I did not know that.
JONATHAN BUSH: He's
actually invited
me to speak to his
annual partners meeting
in the spirit of humility.
He's going to have me go through
play by play all the times I
tried to go to Greylock and
got shown then [INAUDIBLE].
HOST: OK.
JONATHAN BUSH: Good guy, Bill.
But fabulous-- and
fabulous friend.
HOST: We spoke a lot about
the local environment
as a place to start
and grow a business.
Do you have a view
on this market
JONATHAN BUSH: I
share Bill's view,
but I like-- I love the story
of Brer Fox and the Briar Patch.
Don't throw me in the
briar pa-- you know.
And then if you learn how
to be in the briar patch,
you win in the briar patch.
Right?
This is the briar patch.
It's got reg-- it's
the most business
unfriendly, bureaucratic, up
in the nose, attitude emporium.
But you've got a huge
amount of intellect,
a huge amount of capital,
and a huge amount of problem
to solve.
Like the cost of health
care here is off the charts.
The amount of
financial management
that goes on wastefully
here is off the charts.
And so if you choose
a briar patch business
plan that isn't sort of,
invent something really neat
and go instantly
viral really fast,
this is a bad place for that.
But if you choose a
thorny, messy place that's
going to take a lot of
work, this is a great place.
Because you get
all these-- I mean,
we get amazing resumes from
people at Parner's Health that
are brilliant people,
that are passionate,
that work long hours, that
could grock technology as well
as anybody at Google or Athena.
But they thought
that-- how many of you
know any of these people.
Krishna?
We're like, this isn't
change-- this is not
the world changing
things I thought it was.
I'm trolling the
halls, it's political.
I'm not sure that I'm
being as efficacious as I
thought I would be.
It's not like I
thought it would be,
and yet I still want to
be part of health care.
And we can Hoover those
people up and use them.
So it's a great
place for intellect,
and for passion--
for social mission.
It's not a place where
it's like, quick, happy
go lucky virally
explode across anything.
But if you want to be down in
a hard trench for a long timee,
I think it's really good.
And the fact that
[? Helman's ?] disappointed
is kind of perfect.
HOST: But he actually speaks
very highly of the market.
JONATHAN BUSH: Good.
HOST: He speaks very
highly of the market.
JONATHAN BUSH: He told me
that he cried once to me,
oh, my partners in San
Francisco's are making
all the money and I have to
be at the helm of the ship.
I can't get anybody to
do anything great here.
HOST: Well, I think that's
the challenge he spoke to.
He thinks that the potential
is all here, but we haven't--
JONATHAN BUSH: Well
what he has to do
and what the next generation
of entrepreneurs has to do
is-- hats off to the
Google guys and the fact
that they went out--
you ever read that book
Nicholas Taleb
Nassim, Black Swan.
Extremist stand.
And they went from
zero to a billion
to a Google really fast.
And there are those
business plans,
and, San Francisco is tuned.
When one of those
pops, they're ready.
They know how to go that way.
It's like the movie, Wag the Dog
in its description of the movie
industry.
They know tho to call, and
everyone knows what to do
and it all comes together.
Boston is not that.
But the next generation
of successful businesses
aren't going to go
from zero to Google.
There'll be those every once
in while, one will go off
and you'll see it boom.
But there'll be a lot of
really, really fast compared
old fashioned companies
but really, really
slow compared to
instant viral companies.
And that's where I think
the sweet spot of Boston is.
HOST: And I think-- not to
misrepresent Bill-- again,
potential--
JONATHAN BUSH: --We just beat
the crap out of poor Bill.
HOST: Capital intellect
culture lacking.
Particularly a
mentoring culture--
JONATHAN BUSH:
--And that's right.
A mentoring and a
social mission culture.
There is a very-- it's a
little bit narcissistic
and it's extremely
mercenary in San Francisco.
It's quick and it's
no hard feelings.
It's great because
it's failure friendly.
it's like, hey, I tried, I'm
going to pic up my sleeping bag
and my port-a-fridge I'm
going to go to another startup
and do it again.
And I'll either be a billionaire
or I'll be picking up my fridge
and going somewhere else.
And it's fine.
And that mercenary-ness is
good for a lot of businesses.
And we've done so much
with the internet because
of those mercenary businesses
that don't mind failing
and don't mind regenerating.
But there is another
sector-- what
I would call the
fiduciary sector-- which
has been over-regulated.
As soon as we care too
much about baby precious,
we let baby precious get fat,
and he's spoiled, and he cries
and we give him whatever he
wants because we're afraid
he'll get upset.
And we've got a bunch of
sectors of our society
that are like that.
Transportation and auto and
financial services and health
care.
We're big fat incompetent--
oh, but I need a subsidy.
But no you don't,
you need to die
and we need to get
your people out and put
them to work in real companies.
But there are social goods.
They're quazi-social
goods and we
are afraid of hurting
our safety net.
And so we, for good reasons,
create sclerosis-- moats
around them.
And we can still do it.
We can still-- this
book talks about ways
of doing it in health care.
It can be done in
transportation.
It can be done in education, it
can be done in law enforcement.
All these places that are hyper
regulated and over protective,
and therefore when
you watch them operate
from the outside whe you're
used to the Google way of moving
people through the
office or doing anything,
you're like-- I would
shoot myself on my 3rd day
at the police
department watching
the way they have to do a report
downtown when they show up
at a traffic
accident or whatever.
And so those opportunities
are waiting for us
to infiltrate and go more slowly
but make a more profound impact
on society when we succeed.
HOST: We have a governor's
election coming up here.
JONATHAN BUSH: Yes, I've heard.
HOST: Any thoughts on, is there
an opportunity for a candidate
or a party or an initiative or
point of view to help at all,
and if any of this is related
to health care specifically?
JONATHAN BUSH: Well,
it's very interesting.
Massachusetts is
very interesting
because the very centerpiece
of the Massachusetts
success over the
last 20 years has
been related to the development
of institutions who now are--
not through any moral
intent of their own--
like the personification
of the problem.
So we are not a
little bit over bedded
in terms of inpatient beds.
We are massively over bedded.
We're not a little
bit over priced,
we are hysterically
like Kafka overpriced.
And so-- and there are
millions and millions
of people who work in
hair nets and blue smocks,
in unions and in
organizations of other types
and who vote who work
for those institutions.
And so how does the
government pivot?
Because these institutions
are strangling the worker base
and innovation base by
making the cost of everything
higher than it needs to be.
But yet they are the
establishment as well.
And so how do
you-- you can't say
burn baby burn if
you're the governor.
You know, bring down
Mass General, yeah!
Not going to happen.
In fact, they'll even let
them buy up more people
and perfect their monopoly
in the south shore.
HOST: That would be
the next question.
Should they have allowed that
merger to be Attorney General
said yes to that merger?
JONATHAN BUSH: They're
so far over the path
of government invasion.
The things that we could
do in Massachusetts--
it's illegal to open up a
better product across the street
from a hospital.
How about we make it
not illegal to open up
a cheaper hospital across the
street from a lame hospital?
That would really help us with
our lame hospital problem.
It would put a lot of
hospitals out of business,
and that is OK.
Hospitals going out of business
when you're 45% over bedded.
We have 45% more beds
than we actually need,
if you sort of follow
the Dartmouth study,
give everybody what they want,
and pay for it like it's OK.
It's illegal for doctors
to work for companies,
even though entrepreneurs
do better product management
than doctors.
There's all kinds of weird laws
that have sort of built up.
Sort of like, you can
have beer on Sunday laws
or whatever-- these weird
from another era laws.
And so now the
government, rather
than releasing those
laws, is actually
trying to say, but
also charge less.
I'll make you, I'll sue
you, I'll investiage you.
I'll send my investigators
if you don't charge less.
Which is so not cool.
It's sort of a Putin meets
Castro for the people.
And so nobody is a good guy.
There's no way for a
grass roots disruptor
to bring justice to
the over chargers.
Because every time
they do these deals,
it's harder and
harder and harder
for the result in
regulatory deal making.
It's fine for companies like
me with 17 lawyers on staff,
but not good for the dudes
at 94 Codman Road who
are like, how many minutes--
it's like, how much can you
do in six minutes when
talking to the law firm?
So that's the-- I see it
as-- it would be hard.
But you'd have to
make a little pin
size holes in the moat, in
the walls around the health
establishment to
allow entrepreneurs
or just existing
players that want
to try to be entrepreneurial.
And there's a lot
of that energy.
Steward Health Care is a venture
backed into the struggling
Catholic hospitals and
turned into a venture backed
PE-type play.
And now, they have
a lot of things
they're not allowed
to do that they want
to, like close
underperforming hospitals.
But if we let them,
they'd do really well.
HOST: So we probably
have five minutes left.
I'm going to try to hit two
quick questions which I think
we can't contain
within five minutes,
but we're going to try.
JONATHAN BUSH: I can try the
whole snippy short answer
thing.
HOST: OK.
Give it a shot.
Will we be able look back--
if we lok back in six years.
Six years from
now we look back--
JONATHAN BUSH: 20/20.
HOST: 20/20.
JONATHAN BUSH: 20/20
vision this is called.
HOST: That's right.
Are we looking at--
what determines
that Obamacare-- as
we will define it,
as I will use the term-- is
successful or not successful?
JONATHAN BUSH: Ah, yeah.
The problem, when
you do-- when you
make everybody do something,
there's no way AB test.
So Obamacare will be a success.
Because it'll be measured
against whatever we had,
which was nothing.
And so, like oh, well
everyone was covered.
Half the people will look
at and say half full,
and half the people will
look at and say half empty.
And when the mood goes one
way, it'll be more than half
that are against it.
And when the mood goes the other
way, it'll be less than half
that are against it.
Right?
But because there's
no AB test, there's
no people who got to do another
thing besides Obamacare,
then we'll never know.
I think in general, my
final thought on Obamacare
is it didn't do so much
harm that you can't still
be successful.
You can still be an entrepreneur
in an Obamacare health care.
And so, no excuses.
Just get out and do it.
And I'll throw in
one more thing.
If we had done a better
job as entrepreneurs,
Obama wouldn't have
done Obamacare.
It's only because
the marketplace
didn't rise up and
provide something
for the 40 million
people who opted out
that we had it in
the first place.
HOST: Totally different topic.
You're an author now.
JONATHAN BUSH: Yeah, right.
I paid a guy.
Are you kidding me?
HOST: OK, but for the parts
that you didn't pay for.
JONATHAN BUSH: I was the
outline and I was the ranter.
I ranted on my own.
HOST: What did you learn about
yourself, process, rigor,
language, anything.
{INTERPOSING VOICES]
JONATHAN BUSH: I am a
huge, passionate fan
of rigorous process and rigorous
reevaluation of process.
Because my personal
management of everything
is so bad that I just--
I'm in awe of anything
that can actually run
itself well from day to day.
And so this book was
structured into the calendar,
there were certain days for
me to meet with Stephen,
there were half days, whole
days, two hour checkins,
phone calls, and I was
under a time crunch
to get whatever I wanted
to get onto the page
onto the page within
that structure.
And at the end,
it was terrifying.
I came back from my sabbatical
with a paper galley fat
with yellow stickies and
underlines of the things
that I just couldn't
bear about the book,
that we just had to
figure out how to change.
Walked into my office
what my fat galley,
and there was the first hard
cover final copy on my desk.
Congrats!
So there's a certain--
there's something about,
everything in our life is
so fungible, so editable,
so changeable on the fly.
We can lean develop
ourselves in what
we say in our speeches and
our code so continually
that forcing yourself into
a final statement that
will stay still is an incredibly
maturing and humbling,
and valuable, wonderful
honor to be able to have.
HOST: Think you'll do it again?
JONATHAN BUSH: If
everyone buys two copies,
I will do another one.
HOST: I do think we might
have two or three minutes.
If there is one
or two questions.
Sure go ahead.
AUDIENCE: If you
were in healthcare--
HOST: I think just
restate the question.
JONATHAN BUSH: If I was
in charge of health care,
if I was the President
and choosing directions,
I would first choose
that presidents
don't choose directions
for 400 million people.
That's what we have now,
and that's not human.
That's not humanizing.
It doesn't give enough
personal power to people.
They don't feel in charge,
they don't feel good.
Even if what they get is
amazing, it doesn't feel good.
I mean I always felt like world
peace foisted on me by force
doesn't feel that great.
Right?
Whereas world pe-- I
know that's extreme.
Forget that one.
Do you know what I mean?
When someone forces
you on something--
so if I was the
maximum leader, I
would try to make it possible
for many, many, many choices.
Many, many, many ways
of the word health
care to be expressed
throughout society.
I think that's the one problem,
the biggest single problem we
have with health care the United
States today that the word
health care is now federally
litigated down to a very
specific definition of
an all-you-can-eat buffet
of interventions with no mental
health and no emotional support
groups and no good food.
That's the definition of
health care in the country.
And you are not allowed to sell
health care if it;s not that.
And you look at the claims
data like, sex life, friends
at work, mean boss-- these
things correlate to health cost
way more than pap
smears, mammograms.
Mammograms would just show now
that adverse correlation health
stats.
Actually bad to get mammograms.
Canadian study.
Look it up.
So the idea that some one
group-- no matter how smart
or well meaning-- get
to decide what it is
is that thing that we ought to
be a little more humble about.
A little more like, pull
back, get a definition
that still provides a safety
net, but is small enough
allow for a lot AB testing.
A lot of crazy ones to come
and try on kooky stuff and say,
guess what?
This is my health
care, and be OK.
HOST: Thanks.
We have one last one.
AUDIENCE: Jonathan, you talk
about making more informed
decisions-- what
if it, what if--
JONATHAN BUSH: Right, so the
question is, what-- in the book
we talk about the
ignorance economy
and how hard it is that
the patients don't even
understand-- if they could get
financial benefit from making
good health care
choices, how would they
even know what choices to make?
I believe from an-- if you're
an entrepreneur watching this--
I don't think that
the step will be
from where we are to
patients empowered.
I think the first step will
be caregivers empowered.
It'll be entrepreneurs, doctors,
hospitals, these kooky clinic
types in this book
that accumulate--
that have enough deep
cuts of clinical knowledge
to understand the
coding and the referral
game and the sophisticated
payment picture
well enough that they can
start to shop and profit
from shopping in their
patient's behalf.
Then the people
who are now trying
to get those shopping
doctor's attention
will need to start
doing some product
management to explain
it to the doctor.
And once the doctor gets it
to where they understand it,
it'll be packaged close enough
that the first super consumers
will be able to shop for
it without the doctor
in the middle.
But that's-- the next decade
or two is going to be doctors
and those in the role of doctor
or caregiver learning to shop
and to profit from being really
good shoppers as fiduciaries
for their patients.
That's the first way
of in my opinion.
That's a good one to end on.
So everybody go
start a company where
you're a caregiver
shopping for consumers
and get onto Athenanet and
we will do your shit work
that you hate and suck at.
HOST: OK so on that
note, Jonathan Bush,
author of Where Does It Hurt.
For those of you who were too
shy to sit in the front row--
JONATHAN BUSH:
--missed a free copy.
That's why they didn't
sit in the front row.
HOST: Let's try to reserve those
for Googlers if we can, please.
Sorry Athenistas, but I think
we might get something back
in profit.
JONATHAN BUSH: That would be
weird if we came here and took
your food and your employees
and the books that we brought.
HOST: So Googlers,
come grab a book.
This can be found probably
in the next ten days
on our YouTube channel.
I think it's at talks Google
is the YouTube channel.
But just search for
talks at Google.
And really a
pleasure to have you.
Thank you so much.
JONATHAN BUSH: Oh,
this was great.
Thank you guys all very much.
[APPLAUSE]